this is bomani a martial Eagle the
largest African Eagle they have enough
power in one foot to break a human arm
as powerful as they are their strength
in numbers continues to decrease in the
wild martial eagles weigh in at around
14 pounds with a wingspan up to eight
and a half feet
bomani is native to sub-saharan Africa
preferring urban woods wooded savanna
and thorn bush habitats he is an apex
predator sitting at the top of the avian
food chain unfortunately they are being
persecuted by humans mistakenly believed
to be a predatory threat to livestock in
reality domestic animals make up a very
small percentage of their diet add to
that a shrinking habitat which reduces
prey the martial Eagle population is
dwindling fast this is the martial eagle
this is the hyacinth macaw it's big it's
bright and it's vulnerable to lots of
threats the largest parrot by length in
the world it can grow up to 40 inches
their feathers are a beautiful striking
blue unfortunately their good looks have
made them highly desirable in the
illegal pet trade fetching upwards of
$10,000 hyacinths are native to Central
and South America primarily in the
scrublands at the outskirts of the
rainforest it is an affectionate bird
but its powerful beak carries over 200
pounds of pressure per square inch
strong enough to crack a coconut their
diet in the wild consists mostly of nuts
from native palms beyond being a hot
commodity in the pet trade hyacinths are
watching their habitat get converted to
farmland leaving them less and less
space to live this is the hyacinth macaw
this is the northern bald eagle an
iconic bird that we almost lost for good
only a few decades ago northern Bald
Eagles are the larger of the two
subspecies of the bald eagle their
wingspan can reach over seven feet they
are powerful fliers that soar through
the air reaching over 40 miles per hour
when gliding they're excellent predators
attacking from above with their long and
sharp talons
by the 1960s their population was
decimated with less than 1000 left in
the wild chemicals from pesticides
traveled up the food chain rendering
these top predators sterile or unable to
lay healthy eggs thankfully after
massive regulations were put in place
they have made a near full recovery
today loss of suitable habitat is still
a threat as they are very sensitive to
human activity this is the northern bald
eagle
this is Oliver a Humboldt penguin named
after the Humboldt Current in South
America it's estimated that less than
12,000 remain in the wild his size may
not show it but Oliver is a fully grown
male Humboldt are distinguished by their
black backs and Tails and by a black
band across their chest that runs down
the body found along the coast of Peru
and Chile Humboldt penguins live on the
rocky mainland Shores or coastal islands
they have a body made to swim using
their strong wings they get up to 17
miles per hour underwater they love
their fish especially small ones like
the anchovies and herring that they hunt
for in the coastal waters where the
Pacific meets South America unlike
Arctic penguins they live in warm
weather climates and in large colonies
as a collective defense against
predators the biggest threat to these
little guys are entanglement in fishery
nets human encroachment and habitat loss
this is the Humboldt penguin
this is Garrett a sandhill crane if it
wasn't for the Maryland Zoo in Baltimore
he probably wouldn't be here today
Garrett was found wandering around a
Home Depot parking lot before being
rescued by the zoo scattered throughout
Western and Central North America it is
incredibly rare to see them as far east
as Maryland in the winter they migrate
south all the way down to northern
Mexico tall gray and slender sandhill
cranes have long legs and necks their
large wingspan make them incredibly
skilled soaring birds they breed and
forage in urban fields and wetlands and
can often be seen visiting farmer's
fields on the hunt the leftover seeds
while their population has rebounded in
the last few decades loss of habitat and
climate change are still looming threats
this is the sandhill crane this is a
green winged macaw anter colors stunning
so stunning that the illegal parrot
trade has caused its population to
decrease heavily in recent years
the green winged macaw is considered one
of the largest macaw parrots but also
one of the most docile it is commonly
referred to as the gentle giant they are
very sweet affectionate and friendly
with both humans and other birds maybe
because of these easygoing ways these
birds have been known to live upwards of
80 years they favor tropical forests
swamps and savannas their habitat ranges
from Panama in the north across South
America down to Paraguay in the south
they feed on fruits seeds berries and
nuts they're incredibly powerful beaks
are capable of opening the hardest of
nuts and seeds along with poaching their
habitat has been shrinking considerably
and in certain parts where they used to
be plentiful
they've become harder and harder to find
this is the green winged macaw this is
Olivia an East African crowned crane she
is stunning
she stands about four feet tall with a
wingspan of six and a half feet her legs
are long and slender perfect for wading
through grassy areas most the grade the
wings are predominantly white with a
range of colors while her head is full
of golden feathers East African crowned
cranes are well known for their
elaborate dancing these cranes are
omnivores eating everything from plants
to insects snakes small fish and more
native to eastern sub-saharan Africa and
down to South Africa they prefer living
in grassland areas near the water the
crowned crane is the national bird of
Uganda featured on its flag but even
with such iconic status we're losing
them in less than ten years their
population has decreased by over 50%
habitat loss an illegal removal of eggs
and birds from the wild are its biggest
threats this is the East African crowned
crane
this is Sylvester a three-year-old
sulawesi to richtek hornbill endemic to
Sulawesi Indonesia it's once plentiful
population is now rapidly declining
Sylvester is on the smaller side at
about a foot and a half hornbills in
general are characterized by their long
curved bills this specific species makes
its home in the tropical lowlands swamps
and forests of Sulawesi and nearby
islands where it feeds mainly on fruit
with the occasional small animal but
destruction of these areas has caused a
massive drop in population that along
with being hunted for food and the pet
trade has left this once common bird
harder to spot this is the Sulawesi to
richtek horn bell